[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so I hate working from home so I get an
office and I'm super excited about the
office and I move everything into the
office and now I'm working from home
what's up you guys my name is the channa
welcome back to the hazel engine or the
game engine series as is also ignorin
this is the first episode of 2020 and
it's halfway through March and I'm sorry
about that but there's been so many sort
of stuff going on as haven't had the
chance to sit down and do this but now
it is time and you know all jokes aside
this light is so bright
Joe societ it isn't all that bad being
at home in fact I'm cooking a fantastic
Indian curry that's just gonna take
hours but I can do that because I'm at
home in really digging Indian food
lately anyway let's talk about hazel
let's talk about the state of this whole
game engine and I've got it in front of
me here so we're just gonna kind of
we're gonna kind of have a chill episode
today's the first one of 2020 I just
want to talk a little bit about what it
is we're gonna do this year I'm gonna
set some goals this year and by girls I
mean things that I can actually say this
will be done by the end of the year or
at least that's the goal I mean
hopefully we're gonna meet these goals
but the point is we're gonna sit down
right now you and me and we're gonna
talk about what is gonna come in hazel
and in fact we might even tweak a few
things that I'm already disliking just
looking through this code so what
exactly is the plan for 2020 so for
those of you who have been following
this series for some time you know
there's kind of two different branches
of the hazel engine and I'm developing
kind of this public brand which is like
everything on screen step by step kind
of once weekly episodes and like the
benefit there obviously is that
everything I do ever is shown here I
mean there are some kind of pull
requests that do go in to the github
repository under and I don't show them
on-screen but any code that I type you
see it's completely all recorded on a
video but that obviously has its
problems the biggest of which is that's
very slower it's very slow for me to
work like that it's not really how a
software engineer writes a game engine
it's just it's just just takes too much
time so what I do is I also develop a
version of hazel in my spare time and I
call that be hazel
development branch now this branch is
completely available to patrons who help
support the show patreon Cove will
search the churner is of course the best
way to help support this whole series
and this whole engine and my whole life
but the point is that I'm developing
this dev branch of hazel in my time it's
the code that I write for hazel when I
sit down and want to write code which to
be honest has been a very long time
since I've had the opportunity to do so
but I am definitely gonna do more of
that this year that's one of my goals
for the year is to spend more time
actually programming that dev branch has
like 3d rendering and all of that it's
got physically based rendering it's got
like a 3d scene it's got like a kind of
editor style
I am GUI like UI where you can load any
model you can load any texture and you
can kind of play around with all these
different parameters it's a much more
mature version of the hazel engine and
that is in fact where we're heading with
this however I do want to clear a few
things up firstly we are heading towards
that like this engine will of course be
3d and by this engine I mean the public
kind of version the game engine series
version of hazel will obviously be 3d
that's where we're heading
hazel dev is already 3d and has been
this whole time but we have different
goals than the dev branch that's why
there's two different branches if they
were like the same then there would be
no point of even having two different
branches but the fact is we have these
two different versions of hazel and what
we're developing publicly is hazel to D
and then hazel 3d is in that dev branch
that's kind of cool because it lets me
develop these kind of two different
versions of the engine if I get bored
doing like 3d scenes and stuff like that
and I want to do maybe something to do
or something else I can kind of focus my
attention on the game engine series and
develop that branch further but it's
important to understand at the end of
the day it is still all one engine so
anything that happens here will
eventually happen in the dev branch and
vice versa it's just that things
obviously happen in the dev branch a lot
quicker and just a secret between you
and me I'm gonna start live-streaming
myself developing the dev branch for
patrons as well just keep an eye out for
that but that being said I'm gonna say
that for the first half of this year the
Gammage answer is definitely not going
to touch 3d I mean to be honest I'll be
surprised
maybe happy if we actually end up
touching 3d this year in this kind of
public branch the reason is that we've
gone down this 2d path which you guys
voted for by the way 51% of you
Toodee so that's why we're doing today
anyway the point is since we've picked
2d I don't want to kind of turn hazel
into oh this is just an engine where we
just jam features upon features upon
features and we just kind of widen the
technology base and then we optimize it
and then we do all of that that's
useless to me
hazel is a platform upon which you build
applications so what we should be doing
is trying to achieve that kind of base
kind of Minimum Viable Product vertical
slice whatever you want to call it that
will actually allow us to fulfill the
goal of hazel wishes to create an
application that is what hazel is for
it's a framework as a platform for
creating like 3d interactive or 3d
interactive notes to say interactive
graphical applications that's what it is
for and of course games included in this
probably the primary use case for this
engine so that being said what I want to
do in my actual goal for this year is to
basically take something like flappy
bird because that's kind of if you guys
check out that video where I made a game
in around an hour using the hazel engine
and I had to actually add a bunch of
stuff to it that is a good example of
what Hazel's for for building something
like that so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna work backwards so we're
going to take that game I'm gonna take
that example and when I say okay what do
I need to do to make it the ideal
scenario of building on that game of
building that flappy bird clone inside
Hazel's so in other words if hazel was
perfect if hazel was finished and I sat
down to make that game in hazel what
would that process look like what would
I do and there's so many things that are
going to come up obviously and I did
kind of talk about this in the previous
episode I think I talked about well we
actually just pulled some features in
that I had to write I think to make that
flappy bird game even happen stuff like
you know rotation for the quads and
whatever but anyway my point is that we
need to take that and we need to kind of
almost reverse-engineer it not really
reverse-engineer but pet but potentially
even look at something like unity and
see what is that process like what we
like about that process okay let's look
at unreal what do we like about that
process what are we not like about that
process and then take that into hazel
and then try and create something that
is hopefully a combination of everything
we like filled with probably ideas that
we come up with the derp exist in any
other engine and then we'll end up with
something that's actually useable
something that actually does something
instead of like oh hey man
like my maths is SSA and it's like super
fast but I can render a triangle and
that's it shouldn't be drinking from the
snow water bottle but I really wanted
water so to kind of outline a few of the
things that I think are important to
make that happen the first of which and
the kind of the most glaring thing that
I see at the moment is the fact that
whatever we at the moment right in hazel
has to be written in C++
that's not exactly ideal the reason is
that C++ is a very like the turnaround
for compiling C++ code and also the
barrier of entry I'll say to that is
quite high like to get a simple Foss
programmer to write like a little
movement script for a flappy bird game
that's that's not good because it means
that to write anything to create any
kind of interactive application in hazel
you need to know C++ that's that's not
good what we should do instead is use a
much easier language that we'll use as a
scripting language so in other words
we'll use it to interact with Hazel's
API as well as a number of utility like
classes and functions and and all of
that stuff so in other words it's kind
of like just a puppeteer with puppet
strings you don't have to move the
puppet itself you can actually just
attach strings to the parts of the
puppet that you would like to move and
then a puppeteer can easily move that
puppet that's kind of what a scripting
language is and that's kind of the
golfers as well instead of having to
kind of write all of the C++ code to
make anything happen we should just be
able to control hazel like a puppeteer
from within some kind of scripting
language now there's been so much
discussion about what scripting language
to use I mean honestly there's been so
much because there are quite a lot out
there I've kind of tweeted about this
and I've said hey what do you guys think
of this and that the consensus and I
guess also my opinion is that we should
go with Lua the reason is that Lua is
extremely fast it's quite simple it's
very lightweight and it's just very
popular
lots of people know law now there are
syntactic leave like languages that I
prefer and who knows maybe one day we'll
write a Turner language and everything
will be the best but at the moment
not happening so at the moment we have
kind of lower we have maybe Python but
that's a different story
c-sharp is another very good example I
love c-sharp honestly one of my favorite
language is it's so it's so elegant it's
so beautiful but it's quite heavy weight
I mean it requires like a whole virtual
machine if we use mono there's a lot of
Licensing like complexities I'll say
with that as well as the fact that
having been time on a run time and all
that stuff I don't know for me I think
it's a bit overkill especially for an
engine that we're not exactly
commercializing I don't want to make
this a commercial engine I want this to
be a nice and simple and well-written
platform upon which you can also do a
lot of work upon right so in other words
if you wanted to write if you wanted to
use hazel on something and you really
want to see sharp maybe you get out
there yourselves but I don't think that
hazel I don't think I want to go that
direction because it's just gonna make
it too complex and yes it would be good
but at the moment based on what I know
about what it takes to get C sharp as a
scripting language for you know an
engine it's a lot of work I mean okay
look if if we if this was Windows only I
want to clarify one thing if this was
Windows only this engine which is not
obvious in it whenever wouldn't it never
will be because that's weird but if it
was Windows only we of course could just
use like C++ CLI to wrap all of our
supporters code and give access to the
kind of c-sharp runtime and c-sharp
projects you know the ability to kind of
control all that C++ code but I mean you
could use like other functions but sigil
Schloss CLI is probably the most
sensible way to do that there's actually
something that spark he used to use
briefly but it's a lot it is quite a lot
of work to wrap obviously every class in
that kind of super cool CLI intermediate
language but it's possible and that
would be very straightforward and that
would be a lot simpler than having to
embed an entire runtime because
essentially it would just be a c-sharp
app and a Windows Microsoft c-sharp app
that just used a C++ library and that
would be fine but because we needed to
work on multiple platforms we really
have to embed the entire c-sharp runtime
into hazel because how is it gonna run
on an iPhone it's not you need to
actually make sure that you can pi
the C shopper on time for like iOS and
make sure that it works and then you
basically it's basically hazel comes
with a son language kind of thing now
with Lua that's really simple because
lower is like a couple of simple gloss
files I think and that's like it it's
it's like five thousand lines of code
for the whole language like it's really
simple and I think that it's gonna be an
excellent kind of excellent base for us
to build upon and make a so good and
technically speaking again since that
scripting language is like a puppeteer
controlling absolutely everything that
we do there's nothing really that I
can't do like yes on some people might
not like the syntax some people don't
like factor doesn't have curly brackets
so that you know you have to write end
everywhere but like that's just language
that's just the way it is I mean you've
really wanted to you could modify this
in text and make your own language and
then have that compiled to Lua and then
little compiled to anyway whatever I
don't think we're gonna do that the
point is that that's kind of how I see
this going forward and that's what I see
is the major feature for this year for
hazel probably scripting because if we
add scripting then we can actually start
to kind of have a layer upon which
people who might not be familiar with
C++ can actually build a game and then
you know we can kind of underneath the
hood flesh out all of these simple sauce
features
speaking of which signals plus features
the biggest ones gonna be 2d rendering
because we need to get our rendering
sorted out now I did have a batch render
or a series or a batch rendering series
that I did that I did on my channel
they'll be all I'll link the first I've
set up up there is called the intro to
batch rendering that's done now and in
fact I even wrote a batch render within
an hour I'll also link that up there and
if you'll so go check that out if you're
interested in batch rendering because
that's what we're going to start on next
week because that's not going to take
more than like a couple episodes
probably so we'll kind of get that out
of the way so that we can actually
properly rent 2d graphics quickly inside
hazel so that's how that's how step one
and I promise that episode is coming
next week and you can check that out you
meet if you want a head start check that
out right now but the problem is there
is no source code on with us I was
supposed to link to source code in the
description but just to be brutally
honest with you guys I deleted it
I had this thing
that I do sometimes where I just delete
code like it's I've done that a TA I
deleted one month's worth of work that I
had worked on a TA accidentally don't
know how like literally I lost the code
so that's what happened this time as
well it was completely my fault third
this time I still maintain this thing we
had happened with that kind of ei
example and I don't even know what
happened but I just lost it I honestly I
didn't like I didn't know where the code
went I was like why is it not here it's
gone but with the one our batch renderer
I had it like in version control I had
it on gear and I kind of every episode
of the best friend during series I
committed the code for that episode just
so I could roll back if I needed to and
I could see everything but because I
wrote because the batch render a series
happened within like well the batch the
one-hour batch render happened after the
vertex buffer episode but before the
index buffer episode
why did it what I did was I wrote all of
the batch render at the one hour batch
renderer on top of the vertex buffer
episode and then like the next day I
need to record the index buffer episode
so I rolled back the code without
actually committing that so in other
words I just discarded all of my local
changes and they vanish then and then
like an hour later I was like oh that is
a shame
and I was like a big guess I better sit
down and write back hurt again but I
never did because who wants to ride that
entire code basic and I'd have to
literally watch the video that I made
the one hour video that I made and then
kind of write down all the card so I'm
sorry it's gone but we're gonna
integrate it to hazel
next week so that is the current plan
now I did promise we would dive into
some card what are we at 20 minutes man
time flies I don't have to like check my
car in a minute I think that the primary
thing that I kind of wanted to check out
was yeah this kind of um render a 2d
that we had I mean we have render a 2d
storage we have a struct called render
or 2d storage and then we have like a
static pointed that Donna I don't know I
thought this was actually worse than it
was but it's honestly not that bad the
point is if we just jump over here I'll
show you guys where we're at right now
this is what hazel looks like at the
beginning of 2020 we have this kind of
that's some pretty nice smooth scrolling
by the way anyway so we have this kind
of two squares or two rectangles being
rounded this is currently done using
this renderer to D class which has a
whole bunch of functions that are needed
for this however you can see that every
time we draw a quad we bind our kind of
texture shaders well like we bind the
texture shader and then bind the
appropriate texture we calculate a
transform we bind the vertex ray and
then we actually draw it so in other
words we have this kind of one draw call
per quad mentality which is not good
it's garbage in fact and we don't want
to do that and that's why I just fell
off the table anyway that's why this
whole batch rendering series has existed
and that's what we're gonna do here
because this limits us to probably
drawing a couple thousand quads and
that's about it realistically unless
you've got a very B if you compute if
you can handle like 8,000 drop calls or
whatever but what we want to do it we
want to be able to draw tens of
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of quads and that's what battery
rendering is going to let us do so we're
going to kind of take this entire render
a 2d class that we have here and we're
going to convert it into a batch
renderer so this will be the purpose of
this and this is really important there
has to be an easy path for hazel at all
times right the complexity of the code
inside sandbox 2d right so I'm talking
about all of this stuff right I mean
right now it's even it's even more
complex than it really needs to be but
my point is that the code that we write
in here the code that the client has to
write at the user who is using hazel to
build something has to write that has to
be dead simple right it has to just be
really simple it has to work that can't
be like a render at batch render a 2d
begin batch like what is what does that
even mean no one cares I want to draw a
square you know that's the kind of
mentality that I really strongly believe
in because if you're making your user do
a lot of stuff then that's a bit odd
because in so many scenarios if you just
have a little reality check and you have
a look at someone
is using your engine and how they're
using it if they want to draw a textured
quad on the screen it should not be a
hundred lines of code
it should not be five lines of code it
should be draw textured quad done I mean
obviously there's some information that
needs to exist such as like you know the
texture and where the quad is on the
screen and you know maybe there's a
camera or a scene that's being used and
as attitude but my point is that you
can't just have all of his code in order
to make something as simple as that
happen and so that's what we're kind of
kind of do we're gonna probably not
change the API that we have here too
much and we're definitely not gonna do
any kind of like begin end batch stuff
that's weird we're just gonna write this
code in a very simple way in fact what
you see here inside on update is very
likely going to stay the same especially
this section here right I like the way
this API looks we begin a scene right
which at the moment you know it takes in
a camera in the future we'll probably
take in a scene object right and then
we'll do this kind of draw rotate a quad
or draw a quad or whatever and then
we'll do end scene now this obviously
applies to a version of hazel or rather
a let you say a branch of hazel not like
a literal like git branch but just like
a this refers to hazel being used in a
way where you want to control the
rendering itself which I want to allow
as well right because realistically
speaking if you look at unity or any
other engine you're not telling it hey
render a 2d draw me a quad no you add
like an object through the scene and
then like you know you give it like a
sprite or you give it some kind of
appearance and then you know the scene
will tell the renderer hey I need you to
render something on the screen right
that's how it works so obviously like we
don't ideally the client wouldn't even
be interacting with the renderer right
we kind of give all the information into
the scene we make it happen and that's
actually something I'm working at the
moment on Ian hazel dev for like 3d
scenes and everything but in this case
we're going to flesh out this round Roy
2d first and then we're probably gonna
talk about like scenes and maybe like
game objects or like entities and kind
of you know do all of that because
that's going to be not the natural
progression to like that flappy bird
we're at the end of it we should have
like maybe an ST component system a like
civilization system I expect maybe like
a UI system a scripting like runtime all
of this stuff and scenes and everything
where we can just kind of add like a you
know game character object to or
whatever and we can kind of set up the
game so that it actually works at like a
real game instead of having to do
everything manually here so that is the
plan for this year hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you do please hit that
like button patron on come forward
search to China best way to support this
series if you excited for the CEO or as
excited as yes I am then write a comment
telling me you're excited or help me
help support me because that's how this
is gonna happen so and I will see you
next time goodbye
[Music]